we are told a seal and a penguin are
playing a fun game of catch the penguin
swims leftward nine meters then dodges
rightwards another 12 meters the penguin
swims a total time of eight seconds so
goes to the left for 9 meters and then
it goes to the right for 12 meters
what is the penguin's average velocity
during the chase and they say answer
using a coordinate system where
rightward is positive and round answer
to two significant digits or really we
should be rounding our answers to two
significant digits so pause this video
and see if you can figure out the
penguin's average velocity during the
chase
all right so let's just think about it
our average velocity right over here it
is a vector quantity sometimes you'll
see it written like that but sometimes
when we're thinking about
one-dimensional vectors people don't
bother with it then our whether we talk
about a positive or negative sign that
tells us our direction but this is going
to be equal to our displacement divided
by the elapsed time displacement
divided by our time
and so what is our displacement
well we go 9 to the left and remember
our convention is that the left is
negative so it's going to be negative 9
meters
plus 12 meters to the right 12 meters to
the right all of that over our elapsed
time of 8 seconds and what's this going
to be equal to
well negative 9 plus 12 is a net of
positive 3
over 8 and our units of course are
meters per second so 3 8 of a meter per
second but they want us to go to 2
significant digits so i'll write it as a
decimal 3 8 is the same thing as 0.375
but since they want us to round to two
significant digits i'll just say
0.38
meters per second that is the penguin's
average velocity during the chase it
would be approximately this right over
here if we round to two significant
digits
but now let's think about this next
question what is the penguin's average
speed during the chase pause this video
again and see if you can work through
that
all right now let's do it together so
our average speed
and we'll use r for rate sometimes which
is we could be used for speed our
average speed instead of displacement
divided by elapsed time we're going to
be thinking about a distance
divided by
elapsed time
and with distance we don't care about
the direction we just care about the
magnitude so we go 9 meters to the left
plus 12 meters to the right
one way to think about is the absolute
value of each of these values up here
and then we're going to divide that by
our elapsed time
and so this is going to be equal to 21
over 8 meters per second and let's see
over 8 is equal to 8 goes into 21 2
times you have 5 left over 2 and 5 8.
5 8 as a decimal is
0.625 so this is going to be equal to
2.625
if they want us to round to two
significant digits it's going to be 2.6
so it's going to be approximately 2.6
meters per second and we're done